so welcome back to this tutorial on
portal coding alright so today yesterday
we've seen the main polarization results
theorems I will I will do a recap of
that result but mainly I'm going to be
illustrating the algorithms today so
we'll be presenting this material in the
context of channel coding we will have a
binary input discrete memoryless channel
input X output Y and the channel is
denoted by W X is going to be
distributed on to alphabet 0 1 the
output alphabet can be arbitrary even
continuous but for notational purposes
we will also assume that Y is discrete
these are the transition probabilities
probability of receiving y given that X
is sent
I'll be making a symmetry assumption so
that when I say my channel capacity it
will be channel capacity linear chords
in general do not achieve the capacity
of a of any any channel on this the
optimal distribution is the uniform one
on the channel input alphabet so that's
why I want to assume that the channel
has some symmetries so that capacity
achieving distribution is the uniform
distribution on the input alphabet this
way I'm not going to be I'm not going to
have to say the symmetric capacity or
the HTML rate with uniform inputs etc so
when I say channel capacity it will be
the channel capacity due to the symmetry
assumption so it's actually that that
will be true easy channels example
channels that we will use the binary
symmetric
channel and the binary erasure channel
these are symmetric channels the
capacity is achieved by the uniform
distribution and channel capacity is
going to be denoted by C of W it's the
mutual information with X uniform on the
input alphabet because of the assumption
that the channel is symmetric so using
dr. logarithms always this number here
will be between 0 and 1 the basic idea
this is another way of looking at it in
polarization is is the following rather
than trying to design a code try to
modify the channel so that coding is
easy there are two types of channels for
which the channel coding problem is
trivial one is perfect channels the
capacity is exactly equal to 1 in noise
free binary input channel you may say
then you can just send the bits as they
are no need for coding and then there
are the useless channels the channel
capacity is equal to 0 regardless of
what you do you cannot send any
information anyway we don't have to do
perfect coding optimal coding for these
two channels and we don't know how to do
it well it is a difficult problem to do
coding except for these two trivial
cases the channel coding problem is gets
much harder immediately as soon as you
are not in one of these two cases
so the idea as I said is to transform
given channels ordinary channels W R
intra
in turn extreme channels either this
type or that type of course we cannot do
it perfect so you can never start with
ordinary channels and achieve channels
which are either perfect or pure noise
channels we cannot do it I I
in an ideal fashion but we will try to
start with these many copies of these
ones in or 10 channels which are near
perfect or near useless the method is
essentially as follows we take some
number of copies of W independent and
then we will combine them into a large
channel by preserving the capacity
capacity in this combining operation and
then we will split this combined channel
intro back into binary input channels
for various different qualities some of
these are going to be near-perfect
some of them are going to be near
useless it's the idea so before we
design in a code for these channels we
will to the channel transformation or
channel polarization and operative we
will obtain extreme channels on this
side and the coding problem will vanish
that's the main idea so how do we do the
combining the general architecture is as
follows we we take n copies of the given
channel these are the channel inputs and
then we put a transform box here a
one-to-one mapping so these are the
channel inputs these are the inputs to
the combined channel the vector channel
so this is a virtual channel that we've
created now that we will create by
putting in here various different trust
so this is now an N input and output and
we would like to split this channel back
into binary input channels and the way
we will do it is as follows we will do
it one by one the first input the input
to the first bit channel will be u1
okay so let me follow the order in here
so what we would like to have here are
uniform inputs because we want to
achieve the capacity of these channels
so I want to induce the uniform
distribution on the XS the way I will do
it is I will pick a one-to-one
transformation here and I'm going to use
IIT uniform input on u1 u3 etc okay so
IIT uniform here will give us IIT
uniform over here okay so that way the
total capacity of the vector channel
here which is the mutual information
from the input to the output
they did this mutual information is
going to be equal to that one because U
and X are related to each other by this
one-to-one transformation and because
the channels here are independent this
mutual information is simply the sum of
the mutual informations across the
individual channels the channels are
identical so we have n times the
capacity of the individual channels
okay so through this combining operation
in other words we are not losing in a
channel capacity okay
it's a lossless type of combination
operation so we must ensure that we also
will not lose anything as we split this
big channel into pieces and how do we
split it the chain rule is going to be
our template or guideline
this mutual information to total
capacity of the vector channel can be
expressed as a sum or such mutual
information terms now notice that I
there is UI here a single random
variable it's a binary random variable
so the idea is to define a channel for
which this mutual information term is
the channel capacity
okay so each term here we must ensure is
we split the channel that these these
terms here correspond to the capacities
of various binary input channels so it's
clear what we have to do because it is
dictated by the form of these terms the
first channel what is the first term in
there the first term is the first term
under the summation is it's this one
so I have to define a binary input
channel whose capacity is equal to this
the input will be given what will be the
output this is going to be the output
okay so these things are observed anyway
and I will pick this u1 is my input and
this is the output the output is the
output space is pretty large but
nevertheless we have a binary input
channel here okay so now
okay so that's going to be the first
channel let me write in here the second
channel the second channel is going to
have input you to the second term in the
change or the expansion and we have the
entire output plus this additional turn
alright okay so the notation is the
superscript indicates or this notation
here is a subsequence starting at one so
what we are looking at in this picture
is the 8-bit channel corresponding to
whose capacity is equal to this term
here so the ice bit channel has input u
sub I and the output consists of all the
things that are seen in here so we see
the Y the entire vector Y plus all the
previous channel inputs the inputs to
the previous bit channels in other words
okay so this what we see here is a
binary input channel and the capacity of
this channel is equal to that turn okay
so this is the splitting operation all
right
the if--but channel it will be denoted
by W sub I is input u sub I and this
entire collection of random variables is
its output
so the capacity of this bit channel is
is equal to that it's equal to this one
in the splitting operation we have split
the total capacity of the vector channel
into into various intra split the
capacity into capacities of these
individual bit channels and we didn't
lose anything the total sum of the
capacities is still equal to the sum
capacity okay so so far so good I think
it is this is just you know playing with
the chain rule okay so what have we
gained in here here we gained anything
right if we gained anything
first of all why should coding this
channel here be any easier than the
original Channel original channel w
okay that's where we need the
polarization result so we've we
certainly cannot hope to have this thing
work with every Jian for example saying
you take the identity mapping in here
obviously you know you see all the bit
channels that you have created are
exactly the same as the original bit
channels so what you need is
polarization which means you need to
have here good mixing properties in
addition to having a one-to-one mapping
okay so you can have very good mixing
properties here by using let's say a
randomly chosen one to one matrix which
is a lot of ones etc here it and that's
what we do in proving that linear quads
achieved the channel capacity we pick
one linear chord the generated matrix at
random with probable it's very close to
one I it will have full rank and it
would in fact achieve the random coding
pounds without the linearity constraint
so if there is no question that there
are many good matrices that you can put
in here but the question is okay suppose
you put in here a good matrix then the
problem will get extremely complicated
you have a huge output space and doing
ml decoding even for a binary input
channel may be quite difficult so the
real essence of my talk here Paul
according is to have a GN here which has
some structure which achieves
polarization
but can be implemented using more
complex the encoding and decoding
algorithms
okay so what I have said didn't say it
again very quickly polarization is
commonplace okay so it's the rule rather
than exception you plug in in here all
my data matrix you will have good
polarization a random permutation will
do and in fact if you use a random
permutation from binary n-tuples to
binary n-tuples this is equivalent
permutation is not a matrix of course a
random permutation is equal to
revolutions random coding approach so
I'm not saying that you know
polarization I the polarization is
something new okay we were using it we
be using it in the absence of it you
don't have any kind of coding theorem so
it's commonplace if you use random
transformations we will have extremely
good
polarisers they will be stepwise so if
you look at these channels that we've
defined they will the first one will
have capacity equal to 0 almost 0 so you
will have a string of channels whose
capacities are near zero and then there
will be a transition a rapid transition
from 0 capacity to capacity 1 and then
they will saturate so it is stepwise
stepwise polarization you will observe
and then isotropic what I mean by that
is the following
alright here I assumed an arbitrary
order I will first use this channel u1
than u2 and so on in polar coordinates
structured matrices the order here will
be important you cannot change the order
and still hoped I hope to have polarize
channels with the recursive matrices
etcetera that I will talk about the
order is extremely important with
randomly chosen matrices the order in
which you start and through the decoding
is unimportant so you can start in any
order you will still see this stepwise
polarization in that sense it is
isotropic there is complete symmetry in
these are obvious statements
ok I'm saying these things in order to
point out what is different when we
speak about you know this others
transform based on a recursive structure
so the random polarisers they lack
structure hence they are too complex to
implement it is like choosing a random
linear code so what we need is it would
be desirable to have a more complex the
polarizer so in doing this we can give
up certain things we don't need stepwise
polarization we don't need to have zeros
followed by ones it's okay to have some
zeros than a one and then going back
down to zero ok so having irregular type
sequence of zeros and ones it's ok and
we can give up the isotropic property
also if these are going to if these are
going to lead to a lot more complex the
polarizer ok so I having said all of
this how do we do it
ok let's start with I n equal to 2
just two copies of the W this is the
transformation G true that we are going
to be using okay very simple
transformation so x1 here is the modular
to some of u 1 and u 2 and X 3 is simply
equal to u 2 u 1 u 2 are the inputs
these this one should be looked at is
the code word this is the source word if
you like and this is the code word and
this is the encoding matrix encoding
operation so after splitting this is the
combining operation the combined vector
channel after we split it we obtained
histor bit channels ee 1 with input u 1
and output y1 writer just like we had
over here with n equal to 2 and then W 2
it has input ughter output y1 writer and
the previous input u 1 ok so these are 2
bit channels that we've created let's
look at them a little more closely
alright so for the first bit channel
that we have created
ughter is part of channel noise ok so it
is like a random variable which is
interfering with our transmission that's
how we treat it and that's how it was
chosen anyway this is a Bernoulli 1/2
random variable and it it interferes
with our transmission in fact if we
didn't have right through the capacity
here would be 0 but thanks to y2 we we
have some we can estimate u2 and
subtract the estimate in some sense from
from the channel input and then we have
some useful capacity remaining
i Fortis Jennifer so the capacity is not
zero because we have this white show
which lets us estimate u2 and the
capacity of this channel is equal to
that the second bit channel now as we
look at or calculate the capacity of the
second bit channel we are doing
something which will bother you we are
assuming that u1 is not known to us
known to the decoder
well u1 is not known to the decoder
because in general we are assuming that
we we use this to sin theta okay so the
decoder can only estimate this and a
significant number of times the estimate
is going to be wrong so how can we
assume that the decoder for the second
bit channel has perfect knowledge of the
first input
so this assumption so we need a genie at
this point we assume that we have a
helpful genie who provides this
knowledge to us as we go to higher order
constructions and as polarization takes
fault the channels are either going to
be true noisy that we will not use them
we will not send a the data over them so
what we what are we going to do we will
fix the input when we fix the input the
decoder will also know how we fixed it
okay so there will be no need for a
genie if the channel is near perfect
then we will use it to send data but for
a near perfect Channel the previous
decoders will each be able to estimate
the input rewrite them once again there
will be no need to use a genie
okay initially we take we get help from
the genie but is the construction size
gross we don't really need genie as long
as I as long as we do the right thing in
other words don't send any data on
unreliable [ __ ] errors
okay and as long as we have a good
enough decoder that estimates so that
really means that we should be using
only those channels which are
sufficiently reliable okay
so there will be error propagation in
other words you have this sequence of
channels if you make an error in the
eighth bit of the remaining that error
propagates so the goal is not to make
any errors all the way through this
decoding sequence so the decoding is you
see it's going to be based on successive
cancellation it will be done one bit at
a time and it will succeed only if all
the bits are decoded correctly okay so
now this case n equal to 2 contains in
it all the main ideas first of all there
is conservation this is a rewrite of
what we have seen before the sum of the
capacities of these two channels which
is two x CW equals the sum of the
capacities of the B channels the
synthetic channels that we've created
there is conservation of a conservation
of channel capacity and then we see the
first trace of extremization is the
capacity of w1 the first bit channel it
is less than or equal to it is upper
bounded by the capacity of these
channels the raw channels and then the
capacity of the second bit channel is at
least as large as CW why is this the
case
look over here the second bit channel
the second bit channel this one let's
write it again I off you turn to channel
output is y 1 y 2 and u 1 so u 2 is
equal to extra your 3 is equal to X 2
here okay so if I throw away these terms
and look at only the mutual information
from extra to whiter this is equal to C
of W so these other things y 1 and u 1
can only help you that's so it is pretty
clear that this term here is greater
than or equal to that I and this
inequality follows from the conservation
then it's not difficult to see that this
is true directly either but it's trivial
to see that this equal inequality falls
so important thing in here is to
understand the condition for equality
here so when can we have I see W 2
namely this equal to equal to equal to
equal to that I of extra white oh well
it turns out I and it's easier to see
that we will have equality here if and
only if W is an extreme channel in other
words if and only if W has capacity
equal to 0 or 1 in all other cases you
can also see what's happening I mean if
I'm given you one let's look at this
page suppose I'm I'm taught about you
one is the genie is telling me what u 1
is say u 1 is 0 then I am sending this
view to twice there is diversity truth
transmission here I'm sending it twice
over two independent
copies of the same Channel so it's clear
that the capacity of that diversity
channel is going to be larger than CW on
this the channel is either pure noise or
perfect so this should be clear enough
so typically what we have for ordinary
channels we will have strict
inequalities here so we begin with
channels of uniform capacity CW at the
first step what we do is we move we
create two channels one worse than the
original channel the other better than
the original channel so these two
channels you may we may view this
operation is beginning with two channels
and manufacturing two new channels w1
and w2 for more suggestive notation
that's used W - and W plus - indicating
that it is a version of plus indicating
that it's a better channel now the next
step is going to be the following we
will take two copies of W - and then
apply the same trick of double D - we
will do the same thing as we generate
two copies of double D - we will also be
generating two copies of double D plus
so we will also do the same thing on
double D pluses
okay in the next step I sized for
construction we will have four channels
W minus minus EE minus plus created
through this operation with W - and
double D - here and double the - -
double D - plus in here and similarly
for and the other two channels so here
is the size for construction
have this is the size to construction we
repeat it okay now it is terminus we
have w- + W - W - here and double D -
here what is the next step I want to
combine w- + w - in the same way i have
combined the easter so here are the W -
Janis okay so these are virtual channels
now but there yes
so what we do is we combine the inputs
of w- + w - and combine the inputs of
ee+ and double the plus so let me go
back to this picture here we had W - and
W - au 1 here and u 1 prime if you like
in here I combined U 1 and u 1 Prime ok
so that's what we obtain now the
decoding order is important it's crucial
how are you going to do the decoding in
which orders are you going to
disentangle this combination of channels
okay so let's spend some time on this
okay so we had true double D - this
so let's cook this
I have a good one here and I have
another view one here ok u 1 and u 1
Prime
I have a you two here I have a YouTube
Prime in here okay so now III won't do
the combination of you ones and you
choose all at the same time ok let's
first do the following
ok so I left the YouTube channels as
they are I combined the q1 channels
remember the YouTube channel is becoming
accessible only after you one is decoded
ok so let's look at some decoding orders
the one that I'm suggesting is this one
we will first decode this one I must
decode the u1 channels before ID code
the YouTube channels
I will first decode this one why the you
one was you one was here okay so this
use the okay okay so this is your one
and this is u one prime it's just
something else for this they are no
longer the same inputs
okay so u 1 and u 1 prime they have been
combined
it's called this V 1 the first channel
that I'm going to decode this is going
to be the second channel that I will
decode okay so when I do it in this
order I will have removed you 1 I will
have I will I will have knowledge of
port p1 and v1 Prime if I know V 1 and V
2 I know u 1 and V 1 prime knowing given
enables me to to decoding on YouTube and
knowing u 1 prime enables me to to
decoding on this one if I try the
different according order say you know
first this one and then this one would
it work
it would it did work in this in this
example okay so because all I need to
know to decode view to is knowledge of
human I have it so I can do I can do the
decoding I can decode you to after we
won okay so that's fine all right let's
ask the following question can i decode
this one after that
and I decode this one after decoding
that one do you want I don't know you so
there are this channel here they try to
write them over here I have a channel
the second channel I have is his input
future okay and then it will have
outputs this is output y1 y2 let's call
it y1 prime Y true prime Lord I don't
call them
prime prime etcetera this is y1 y2 y3
and y4 but so we started with two
independent copies or size 2
construction and we are now coupling to
two constructions okay so initiated this
is what we had right okay so what I have
let me start over again I have a new one
channel and we want prime channel these
things are virtual channels but they are
channels abstracted they are channels so
if there is nothing that should prevent
me doing on these channels then the
distance you want going to y1 y2 and you
want prime going to y1 prime Y to prime
I have two bit channels so I want to
play the same game on these channels how
do I do it I take the input of this one
and then combine it like this okay I'm
not doing anything else
okay can I disentangle these things in
the same way I have been doing it I can
you said actually I could decode you two
after D one okay so what is the chain of
goocher it is the chain of y1 y2 and you
won this channel here requires knowledge
of y1 y2 and you won so as soon as you
have you won I'm sorry yeah you're right
you're right
so you are saying I don't have I don't
have you won
I have v1 okay I apologize for it yeah
you're right
okay so I have to decode this one okay
thank you for pointing that out I have
to decode this one so that now the sum
of V 1 and V 2 gives me u 1 and having
the having u 1 I can go ahead and decode
this channel this one okay then and I
look
do I have to decode this one next or can
i decode that one that one is the third
chain of decode this one is v3 for
decode this minus v3 both choices are
possible here okay because we have the
required knowledge for decoding either
this one first in the third order or
this one in the third order okay so on
the other hand that's the next step in
the argument
why not do the same thing simultaneously
on these two bit channels as well okay
so we had these two channels virtual
channels that were created and we
combined and split them why not do the
same thing on this ones they smell like
that does this combining operation here
perturb the decoding on v1 and v2 this
is the important question now does this
system in which I apply let's call it v3
now and then before okay so if I do this
apply the data input s b3 and b4 rather
than as u 2 & u 2 prime if I apply them
like this does this change anything what
is the distribution of u 2 & u 2 Prime
what was it it was the uniform
distribution so if I what is the
distribution of V 3 and P 4 the uniform
distribution so the uniform distribution
the uniform distribution induces uniform
distribution over here so nothing
changes more important perhaps is the
following this transformation here is
one-to-one
ok so it's a one-to-one transformation
by I don't change the statistics of you
two and you took pride in decoding V 1
and V 2 I'm not assuming knowledge of u
2 & u 2 prime what I am assuming is that
they are uniformly distributed okay so
by doing this combining operation in
applying uniform inputs at B 3 and B 4
I don't perturb the uniform distribution
on u 2 & u 2 Prime hence it's okay to
simultaneously couple both inputs okay
this is a little tricky but and it is
not very clear when you do it by slides
ok so this is the only possible decoding
order the correct decoding order if you
do not couple the astir then okay that
should be the first this is the second
either this or that may be the third one
but after coupling this has to be the
third input to be decoded
okay if you have followed me so far you
understood it all I mean the rest is
simply you know repetition of these
structures so if you did not follow
anything please ask okay I will do my
best to explain it this is really the
crucial point in understanding the
construction to summarize you see we
have a size two construction two
independent size two constructions two
virtual channels synthetic channels that
we've created so if you do so there are
two different orders you can collect one
bit this bit traversal and one without
so pardon me so there are two different
orderings which end up working right one
where you do this bit reversal
permutation and one get out so there is
no bit reversal here all right the bit
reversal is applied over here
okay I am hiding the bit reversal issue
in this in this presentation okay so
there is no need
okay maybe what the bit reversal is here
let me answer the question right this
way you see the order in which we are
decoding this is the bit reversed order
so at the first input okay so let's
represent integers with bits
let's also clarify this point in using
bit reversal bit reversal language one
two three this Intex these things
starting with 0 okay so natural numbers
are not good okay so the order should be
0 1 2 3 and then you turn these things
into binary representations
so the order in which I'm doing the
decoding is this one in bit reversed
order I am first decoding
okay I'm first recording this one it
takes zero fine the next thing I'm
decoding is this one the third wire it
has in texture okay so I'm decoding this
one the third wire it has in texture
okay so it is it doesn't have index one
but it is if you beat reverse everything
here you get the order in which I'm
doing the decoding so this is the normal
order
and then this is the beach reversed
order recording if you look at the wires
in which order I'm doing to decoding I'm
first decoding the wire with label 0 0
that's the first one then I'm decoding
the wire with in dextra that is this
label 1 0 but if you do bit reversal
okay you can read the exact ordering in
which we do the decoding now the bit
reversal is something which can be
avoided in this exposition I would like
to avoid it because it is just you know
for convenience in writing down the
mathematical formulas you want to write
the change rule in such a way that the
indexing is in the natural order not in
the bit reversed order so at some point
you say I'm going to put in here a bit
reversal permutation so that the change
of time be written in the natural order
so it has nothing to do with I mean the
order here should be understood by
looking at the picture and there is only
one logical order in doing the decoding
in here so let's go to yes you want you
three you to you for this go back
say it again please you to see the order
you mentioned was u 1 u 2 u 3 u 4 read
the first decode you want the order of
decoding is u 1 u 2 u 3 u 4 yes it
doesn't work why doesn't it work okay so
if I first decode you one time which one
you three you you are not done you
decode the first channel that was a
double D - Jenna okay so you had two
copies of W minus and 2 copies of W plus
okay you combine these ones and you what
you want is to obtain W minus minus and
w- + okay only after you decode the
second one that you will have this one a
pls double D plus okay so unless you
decode this future this future you are
saying you one and then this one right
okay so I know what is this channel that
we are seeing in the presence of only u1
and not you two
so the channel you have that is you
torture your Twitter so you you you want
to decode you three before you - so
these are all available to you let's
write all of them y1 y2 y3 y4 ok and
what else you have u1 u1 available you
don't tell you 3 available to you now
what you want is something like this
u3 y1 y2 okay now for
we've decoded this one now we are
decoding that okay you three the
interference that's coming into this
channel is coming from you for but you
see you for it doesn't show up very
clearly in here it's not a w+ channel
yet it will become a w+ channel only
only after you decode you to this is w
minus EE plus but these are virtual
channels this will become doubly plus
and that will become w- only after i if
we go back to you know the the picture
if i have a picture yeah in this picture
this picture is better yeah okay now you
are suggesting do you one first and then
to you three okay so look at you for you
for is at this point you for is on the w
channel okay it's not a w+ trainer so
you have a difference the formulas get
mixed up I'm not saying that it is not
going to work recursive structures will
get is the order in the order is the
order is well I mean obviously you can
choose any decoding order you want the
question really is with it polarize
under any decoding order I can show you
very clearly that it will not polarize
for example if we start with you for
intuitively I'm thinking yes
now when you polarize the channel there
is a good channel and a bad channel was
polarized through two bad shells yes you
for went through two good channels seems
to me that you want to first decode u1
or equivalent
you want to fix you one it's gonna be a
really bad channel right yeah this is
going to be a bad channel if all the
previous ones have been decoded this is
going to have diversity for one good
channel and one bad channel okay now
don't think only in those terms also
think into in terms of the recursion
okay preserving to preserving the
regularity of the construction okay what
maintaining analytical tractability okay
so that's why you know I showed first
I'm not saying that it is not going to
polarize under various other decoding
orders this is not a claim I'm making
but I'm not going to be able to analyze
it okay because you say here I'm
ensuring that in tests according order
you combine through W minuses and then
through W pluses if you do it in some
other orders what you will be doing is
will be combining you know various
different channels if the channels that
are combined and split are not going to
be identical what happens then is who
knows it may still polarize it may still
work but this is if you like this is a
suggested order so now we are we have
the size 8 construction we had true we
create two independent copies of the
size for construction and I change the
wiring water a little bit now you see
that I'm doing the decoding in the
natural order okay so a bit reversal
permutation has been applied on in this
transformation the wiring has changed a
little bit if you have noticed okay we
had adjacent nodes connected to each
other near the channel now they are
connected to each other at the source
okay so this is the difference between B
traversal bit reversed order and natural
order
okay so but look at this cross-section
here there are four wires here
connecting the bottom half to the upward
part okay so if you cut these wires you
have two independent copies okay so the
the way you want to proceed with the
decoding is you know you connected this
one and that one you will unentangled it
first okay
so first this meant and that one move to
the next one okay if you do it in the
order that I did I say it correctly
maybe not okay well anyway this is the
construction the decoding order is
okay I wish I had to run it the other
way around okay so the decoding order
yes we can do the decoding in this order
first this one done this one okay then
that and this one be traversed order the
decoding quarter it doesn't make any
difference
yeah because you you have you have the
same signals appearing in here
it's the ones over here okay
so I well I'm running out of time so I
will stop in two minutes whether I I
won't be able to get through all the
intended material but let me just
illustrate what happens if you keep
doing this transformation so we have a
binary erasure Channel the binary
erasure channel has the nice property
that when you do the combining and
splitting operations you create on the
binary erasure channels and then it's
easier to calculate the capacities of
the W - W plus channels so if you
combine two WS this is the W - you
obtain the erasure probability gets
transparent there's two times the
erasure probability of the original
Channel minus epsilon squared and the
erasure probability of the better
channel is epsilon squared so this is
the beta Channel and these are the
capacities of the binary erasure
channels that we create by this
construction for size 16 so the original
channels are binary laser sinners with
erasure probability 1/2 and week it's a
size 16 construction the first channel
has Kappa
almost zero and that the second chain of
the third chain of now this is the the
reason why I drove the figure in that
different order is now we are doing the
decoding in natural order and you see
that it's small indices we have some
very bad channels and as the index gets
large towards the end as you might guess
the capacity approaches becomes near one
so 16 is too small a size for such
constructions we don't yet have
polarization but as we keep increasing
the size of the construction most
channels are either at very bottom or at
the very top all right you got a higher
length although it is not it is not
clear from the figure the fraction of
channels for which the capacity is
between zero and one namely those
mediocre channels that fraction is going
to zero it is difficult to see it from
the figure so this I I think this is a
good point for me to stop and next time
I'm going to talk about martingale for
analyzing analyzing and proving two
polarizations there is a martingale here
this is another way of drawing the same
figure this is size 2 to the 7
construction 128 nodes in here and they
correspond to the capacities of various
channels created and then there is this
traceability okay so you create two
channels a good channel and a bad
channel this is true descendants okay
so if you do the combining and splitting
in the order that I have described what
we have is a martingale to expect this
barrier of the capacities of the
children is equal to the capacity of the
originator okay so you have a martingale
in here and then it's a bonded
martingale between 0 & 1 and you have
all the nice properties that comes with
bonded martingales it converges
converges in almost surely in l1 l2 you
name it ok so you not only have the
capacities here converging but they also
are stable
okay so you for example this converging
to 0 it does not oscillate or the
fraction that does oscillation also goes
to 0 okay so you need this this is
important because otherwise is to change
the construction size good channels
could become worst channels and so on so
the whole thing could reshuffle itself
and you wouldn't be able to use it so it
is not just for the sake of proof but
also for gaining practical insight it's
important to understand the martingale
nature of the construction here so with
that I will stop and see you tomorrow